Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina,
and here we are.
Hi Bobby.
Hi Mom.
Hello.
Disturbing.
I'm going to put that on Dr Drew's list.
He would definitely have a
lot of empathy for that guy
because he was homeless. That guy. Yeah,
he's the homeless voice. Great Voice Guy.
Yeah. It's funny. Like
I was just going to go,
well what happened to him and then like
I know it's something bad. Right? Well,
I mean he probably got a big break and
manage your money and then he blew it on
drugs and now he's homeless again.
So yeah, it's kind of predictable.
You kind of pick up on these patterns.
It's pretty sad. It's pretty sad.
It is sad. It is. That's pretty
sad. I mean, sure. It's hilarious.
Is it funny or sad? That's
Kinda, yeah, no, it's actually,
that should be the theme of all our
clubs. Is it, is it funny or sad?
I think it kind of is. Yeah. Um, yeah.
I'm going to ask me how my pee went.
Yeah, I'm sure people are dying to know.
That's good. Thanks for asking.
Great. Seven months pregnant.
So I go a lot.
Yeah.
You didn't think well I was going to
add more toilet paper or the bedroom.
I knew you were going to bring this up.
How dare you. First of all, I had,
I keep that thing stocked all the time.
I bring up about,
I bring up an entire fucking case of
toilet paper. Yeah. You know what I mean?
I got back from dropping your kid off
and there was none there. Yeah. Well,
did you use the tissue?
There's a backup tissue box that
I put there for a reason. Yeah,
it's a backup system.
Why not stock it with the TP though?
Oh my God.
Because we just ran out like this morning
at 4:00 AM I took my last wipe and
then I woke up at six 45 with a kid. It
wasn't the first thing on my list, Tom.
Oh, why does it, why am I the
keeper of the 12 panel? It was gone.
You're the keeper of the House. I,
I can't, I can't keep up laughing.
I got other stuff. I got dogs
diarrhea in the middle of the night.
I got seven months.
I'm so much pregnant.
I got toddler and my friend
visiting. It's a lot. All right,
so you want to,
God,
I should tell the story that I
want to fucking murder her. Yeah.
Christina proposed that.
Um, we kill our dog, Betsy.
We don't kill it.
All we need to do is let her loose in the
hills around here and there's a lot of
coyotes and if something were to
happen, I'm the psycho. I'm the psycho.
I'm sitting here like, no babe, we can
figure it out. And you're like, no,
I can't do it. I can't do it anymore.
I'll tell you. Here's why. Uh,
the baby keeps me up a lot of nights too.
Like they cry a, I'm, I'm tired already.
You've been gone a lot.
This month has been hard. At
least once a month. This guy,
damn dog gets diarrhea and then now I'm
up at night taking her out two or three
times it,
I don't know what been the vet.
She's eat special food to
balance this problem out.
She gets diarrhea about once a month,
once a month,
and I don't know more than other dogs
had been. Of course the diarrhea,
but it's usually not that frequently.
It's not this consistent.
Got Dogs that I've been fif might get
it once every year and they eat the same
stuff that falls on the floor.
And here's the thing.
Yesterday is when she must've gotten it,
but I kept her away from all the
droppings from the foods a table. She,
there's no like,
I don't even know what she,
she can't get into trash because there's
no, there's no supply around her. I know.
I don't even know what she's doing.
She finds her way into things though
that you don't even think about.
I'm sure there's no access.
She has no access to these things.
I'm beginning to think it's
something inside of her that's wrong.
I don't think it's a diet.
I mean killer.
We'll definitely do away with
the problem like you're saying,
or letting her into the hills a little
14 pound Brussels Griffon just for a
night. If she survived,
she's, you're gone. Then she's
back. She's back in the fold.
She wouldn't live an hour outside of this
house. Now. I Know Eagle would get her.
Oh so fast squirrel snatcher write up I,
I'm at a loss. I really don't
know. I don't know what is wrong.
It's like I can't, I can't be
up at night with two babies now.
And the fucking dog. That's the
thing. Yeah, I'm going crazy.
Some of you are probably watching.
You're noticing my Mickey mouse shirt.
Nobody's noticed it is real.
I do it because my son has taken to
loving Mickey mouse and it's a way to bait
him into affection.
So I bought a bunch of Mickey Mouse.
He really did this right
when I walk around the corner
for the first time in the
day, he's like Mickey and I
go, yeah, yeah, of course.
Of course. He gets all excited and it's
worked so far it's work. He's like,
and then every once in awhile
he'll read notice and be like,
you got Mickey on your shirt. And
I'm like, yeah dude. It's how I roll.
He loved it and then I don't wear it. And
he's like the fucks up with your shirt.
Yeah. Cause he's strictly making
right now. Yeah. Pretty cool.
And he sleeps nothing like segway
from that into our opening clip. He,
Ms Tom Leykis. Okay, perfect.
There it is. Did you like the
clip? That was it. That was it.
You liked it. Let's try that again.
Let's try it out. Try it out. Try it out.
Here we go.
I'm Dr. Lindsey Doe,
clinical sexologist and host
of this sex curious show.
Sexplanations today I'm going to
answer are very popular. Question.
How do I eat ass
is Scott
well, well, well go to your mom's house.
Obviously. Full disclosure,
this is more a video for you.
Some of the uh, hesitant ladies
that listen to the show. Um,
a lot of us veteran guys could give
this speech ourselves if we want.
It might be better for you to hear it
from one of your kind, you know? Yeah.
Hopefully you'll take notes. Yeah,
you do have a pen and paper. Good.
Hopefully you'll eating ass.
Also known as tossing the salad.
Rimming cleaning the kitchen,
playing the rusty trombone,
anal Lingus and Colo sex is
actually pretty simple. Step one,
ask your partner your ass hole.
The next time I go down on you.
How would you feel if I made out with
your butt while you masturbate? Wow,
she's cool.
I like her.
You know it's interesting to me is people
that call themselves sex experts now,
he's not even really necessary.
I mean given the internet,
you can just Google like just like this.
I want you to ask me exactly the way
she said this one. Sure, go ahead.
Whereas I go down on you.
How would you feel if I made out with
your butt while you masturbate? Yeah.
How would you hold on.
How would you feel if I made out with
your butt while you masturbate? Cool.
Let's do it right now like that.
That'd be my answer.
How would you feel if I made out
with your butt while you master,
but I feel great about it.
Did you ever think that I would put those
words together in a sentence like ever,
ever. I never 41 years.
Never said that before.
He's a super cool chick so she
doesn't look like the type to eat ass,
which is might be a she.
She kind of comes under the radar like
you meet her for a drink and you're like,
oh maybe she'll kiss. And then she's
like, well we didn't make out what you're,
but while you dropped off, how'd
you feel if I may go step two,
once you have consent,
it's time to get ready.
Avoid giving anything bad to their asshole
and getting anything bad from their
asshole. Here are the infections
that can go from mouth to anus,
anus to Matt herpes, gonorrhea
and chlamydia, HIV, syphilis,
hepatitis a and hepatitis B. Lastly,
gastrointestinal problems and parasites.
Light basically the things that cause
food poisoning might be hanging out and
you don't want to put those in your body.
So here's a good heads up.
But what's I could, I wish I had like a,
these things right here make me think.
Don't necessarily just eat
a stranger's ass. Yeah.
I mean without this I would have been
like you should, but now I feel like shit,
you should, you should meet people
right away. But now I'm like, oh,
I didn't know you could get all these
things that you should discriminate a
little, a little bit, a
little bit, but not that much.
Where are you the kind that would just
toss salad willy nilly with girls it out?
No, I'm not just handed out for
sure, but I mean, I dunno if she,
you know, she looked like she
didn't have those in and then, yeah,
if she looked like she doesn't have
those, well here's the thing. I mean,
I wouldn't ask for a blood panel. I would
see this nasty girl. She nasty as hell,
but he's not nasty, but she looks like a
nice girl. So this girl, you'd be like,
she's,
she doesn't even do all this stuff,
but she does and she doesn't do a lot
of want to know. I mean, I can just,
I don't have any STDs. I wonder. Yeah.
I wonder how, I know it was quite common
to have a lot of these things. Yeah.
Do like, do you just like,
uh, do you volunteer it?
Like when you feel like it's about
to go down? I think you have to,
I think he knows that
that's gotta be like,
I feel like that'd be an immediate
does then that just kill the queue. Um,
no because I mean I know people that
have these things and relationships and I
think, I think it's more the relationship
talk. Well yeah, that's what I'm saying.
That's different though. What about when
you just meet someone and you're like,
it's each other's asses. Wait,
but I've got hepatitis A, B,
syphilis, HIV, chlamydia
and gastrointestinal.
I got all these things.
Well I think there are people out
there that are like, that's the,
that's the risk I'm going to take.
I remember this,
I remember how upset he got.
He hooked up with somebody that we
knew and then after they were done,
she was like, I got to tell you something.
And he was like, what? Because I have, um,
no, that's not a big deal.
He was like, what? Oh my God.
Cause I have that thing that everyone
has. And he goes, what do you,
what do you have? Herpes? What do you
mean everyone has, she goes, well,
a lot of people have it and he's like,
why don't you say it before we get it,
before we did it, but then he didn't. He
got, he didn't get anything. Let's see.
Yeah.
Some people say that's just the calculated
risk you take for being with that
person and you just wear a condom
and that's the risk. Not a big deal.
I don't think in a relationship. I'm
talking about one night stand. Yeah,
the one night stand.
It's a calculated risk.
It tells you how this maybe I'm not
broken out right now. There's no outfit,
but at least saying it is a big thing.
Disclose.
I think it's your moral duty
about a lot of people don't.
That's how things get spread.
See,
that's why I wasn't promiscuous
in the nineties before I met you.
I swear this is the only reason I
was in a hoe. I mean not the only,
but I was so afraid to get in all
this stuff, man, and now look,
now we're two virgins together. You sure
got hoes fucking uniform. All right,
let go that next one.
Step three set of time.
I'm sure you don't want to go down on
someone and find a dingleberry of poop and
pubes sticking your ass hole.
Watch your bowel movements.
Healthy ones look like this.
Unhealthy ones look like this.
Shower and wash your
whole bucket with soap,
especially the anus and all those little
crevices that make it look like a star.
Stay outside though.
Don't go inside.
Oh again, she's with the, she had to tell
you to stay outside. Just like that guy.
He's like,
you want to figure us?
Don't put your finger in your
household setting at time.
Feel like a little bit of a mood killer.
What are you talking about? She's like,
set a time like fake, like I want to
your ass. Cool. Do it at seven no,
I think that's really cool because I feel
like you've demanded things like how I
want to put my mouth on stuff. I'm
like, hey bro, I just came from a hike.
My crotch smells like a zoo.
Do you think you could not put
your mouth on my parts right now?
Can we make an appointment and then
you can do this when I'm clean. No,
because I remember the last
peg that I did that too.
You know,
I just met her at a bar and you
know we had more drinks and then,
but that was probably a big
contributor was drinking. Yeah, no,
that I think about it.
Yeah cause you don't,
you lose your sense of taste and stuff
and judgment and your, your brain,
you're like, yeah go for it. Go, go
for it. Go for it. Doesn't matter.
My brain done.
It's funny cause like my brain didn't
when I was in college and stuff.
I never sacked guy's stuff just willy
nilly. I'm never, do you know that?
I've never put my mouth on just
a rogue, a painter. I've never,
not once. Not only a
stranger's Dick. Okay,
well one of us is not
very adventurous stuff.
Four, acquire some dams
for a layer of protection.
They reduce the risk of all the bugs I
mentioned earlier and cover up the smell
and taste of asshole.
Well, there's the, isn't that the
biggest deterrent of them all?
The smell and the taste of the asshole.
The,
you mean it's the biggest
fucking seducer of Brill.
Yeah, of course. What do you mean if you
don't have the taste, what are you doing?
You want it to be doing a little Tang.
You don't necessarily want,
it's super tiny, but
ah, you just want to go.
Why can't you just have like a clean ass?
It's not possible for you.
Cause I know where this is going.
This is all for you,
but you don't have a clean ass.
There's no way you can because
of the amount of hair and
sweat cleaner right now.
It's not possible.
Trim it too. And then you can
just do what's possible with you.
You're so Harry, Harry and gross. Hmm.
Step five with all preparation in place,
play, play with all sorts of body parts,
kiss, massage, whatever it takes
to get all riled up before.
Okay,
go for step six.
When you lightly blow on the Asshole,
the blowing will not only
light up this sensitive spot,
it will walk the smell toward you.
So you can evaluate whether or
not you want to proceed. Oh,
that's okay. That's actually
a good tactic. You see that
I'm too, I blocked it out. What
did she say? She's saying yes
below towards it and then
as you blow towards it,
your airway hit the asshole.
Some of the air will come back
and if there's a a scent to it.
Yeah, I mean I just generally I engage
in practices where there's like, no,
I don't have to do that. What
do you mean preliminary? Well,
how would you know then? No,
I'm just saying that I don't,
I just stay away from activities that it
has to do this much preparation for any
activity that does this.
What it sounds like,
it's a lot like I have to find
out if this person has STDs.
I have a fine after
that to clean their ass.
I think the worst was the dental dam and
she's like, Hey, like imagine you're,
you're like, I'm going to eat
that ass. And I'm like, hold on,
let me get this dental dam out.
Why? Oh No, just see. That's how I would
prefer to do it. On somebody. All right.
Why don't we start with that?
I'll get a dental dam and then
can I wait until I'm not pregnant?
I don't want to do, I'd throw out.
I mean that's kind of the real for me.
That's a whole genre of porn, right?
Pregnant lady eating some guys,
but I'm sure I'll look
it up later to confirm.
So nasty. What's wrong with people,
man? Yeah, but she's right about that.
That's a good tactic.
I can't blow a little air towards it.
It just seems so labor intensive for loop
and put a dam in place and had enough
lube to keep things soft, but not so
much that the anus thinks it's leaking.
Yeah. It's a lot of thinking. It's too
much. Yeah. What? I just do it to them,
it's do normal things.
Step eight don't literally eat ass unless
your partner is into a poking feeling
out of nowhere. I recommend working
your way to the anus from the buttock,
from the genitals to the
paraniem inner thighs and up,
kissing and touching
with your hands licking.
If you liked writing the cheeks and going
straight in for asshole can feel quite
jarring.
Hmm. Sounds like you've experienced. No,
I just, I did feel that it's from her too.
I was like, Ooh, she
really knows what she is.
Once you're at the site, think licking
gentle sucking, kissing and tickling.
Even making contact and not moving
at all can be incredibly arousing.
The anus is densely
packed with nerve endings.
That's part of a concentrated area of
erogenous tissue and it's slightly taboo.
So there's a thrilling adventure and
doing something pleasurable that society
tells us not to.
How many people you think that are
watching her really need to wash her?
In other words, do you need the full
lesson of how to do this? I guess a lot,
right?
So that means somebody who's,
who feels like they're really benefiting
from it. I clearly, but like I said,
like do we need another
sexpert in the world?
I feel like you could just Google this
shit. How do I eat acid? It comes up now,
but it's been covered. You
know what I mean? I Dunno.
I've never heard of discussed this way.
So there was,
to me it feels pretty intuitive. I mean,
except for the blowing thing. That's a,
that's a tip.
But a wash your ass wash your ass is
if you don't know to do that. Yeah,
don't eat. Don't literally eat someone's
ass. It's kind of intuitive. No Shit.
Yeah. Choose someone's be
whole. Yeah. I don't know, Eh,
it's not my thing, Tom. It's just not my
thing. It's never going to be my thing.
We're going to get you into it.
Check in. I'm not staring. Ask Your
partner questions wetter deeper.
You could ask any
questions like how is it?
But getting a yes or no answer means
you're not caught up in conversation when
they likely want your mouth getting
back to business. Okay. I have,
I'm getting a little nauseous
from licking butts holes.
I can't even fathom
how many fucking steps this woman have.
Anal Lingus is hopefully
pleasurable for everyone involved.
If you're not into it,
consider 69 so you're getting oral sex to,
or any new position for that matter.
You know what she,
she should have talked about the,
uh,
the squat and sit where like you lay on
your back and then a guy steps over your
face,
squashed down,
puts his mouth parts disaster
directly in your mouth. And then
I can't think of anything more
overwhelming. Can you even imagine?
That's a beautiful thing.
I remember my parents telling me
about it the first time. Can you,
I can only imagine because I
have like, I have, you know,
just like squeeze your butt cheeks and
stuff and I have felt the heat that comes
out of that region with you.
Like I can just imagine like
the heat that and the hair. Oh,
it's nice.
I can sell and that you have to
hold a squat for a while. Yeah.
Yeah.
You got to hold it for awhile.
Why don't we do the Hammock trek that
that guy did? And Venezuela. Oh yeah,
the macafee the,
yeah,
you cut a hole out of the hammock and
then you can kind of squat on that.
And then that's just to make brown though.
He wanted the girls to Brown in his mouth.
And the way you can also do it for Butler
taking I guess there's a tip she liked
to watch these really gross.
That's a whole other level.
Speaking to Browning. Um, lot of people,
a lot of people weighing in on the
poop pile. Your time is over man.
Defecation and yeah cause
you've been found out. Uh,
you know some people
said Oh you there was a,
would you rather when you said you
didn't want to poop outside and yeah,
cause I'm thinking of of it as
open up the side of the street.
Like,
like that's what we were talking about
in India as people just shitting on the
side of the road. That to me is
different than the poop pile,
which was just like a almost
like a spiritual event.
Yeah.
You know what I think is the most Yana
compelling evidence against you poo poo
pile is the way that
you described the setup.
Now I would like one of our listeners
to go back into the vaults and maybe dig
up the audio of the first time you
described exactly how the poop pile wet
because I'm pretty sure you've
described it differently. No,
it wasn't this time. You said there was
a uh, uh, steps hammered to a tree. Yeah,
that's true. The first time you
just said, you said it was a ladder.
What's a makeshift ladder?
Oh,
so is it a tree with steps cut put into
it or a make shift lumps and calling
that a makeshift ladder?
The steps nailed into the tree.
That's to me is a tree ladder.
That, that specific thing.
It's a tree that we put steps on. Well,
yeah, that's true. It is. In essence,
it's a tree that you
guys would shut out of,
but there was no mention of a tree
up until this last time. He's a tree.
That's what we had the tree. What do
you mean there's no mention of a tree?
I don't, Yana, I don't recall any
mention of a tree. Well you don't,
luckily for you, for me,
for all of our listeners,
I was able to spend time this weekend
with somebody I live with during the poop
highlighter and I brought
it to his attention.
You mentioned to me like bring
it to his attention. So I did.
And he's just going to lie to
all right case.
Um,
there's been a lot of controversy lately
about whether the poop pile is real and
as somebody who lived
with me in that time,
can you comment on too as to
whether it was racial or not?
Poop pile is definitely real.
Um,
I mean it was something
that everybody took part in.
It wasn't just me and Tom
and Justin had a roommate,
but it was like a neighborhood thing.
Kids would come over and
that I get excited and tell
their kids they come around
over. But we had, I mean,
we had the ladder and kind of in the
back where the tree was the climb up,
everybody would take a dump pile up.
I mean Poopa yeah,
I mean,
now what about the accusation that
it as guys are that age in college,
there's no way we would do that
because it would deter, you know,
girls from coming over. So we were
trying to get late. No, definitely not.
It never happened.
I mean that was,
that was what that was our
thing is what we're known for.
Never stop you just for,
it's like that's the poop
powerhouse. Yeah. Let's go get laid.
Yeah.
And sometimes even they would
want it definitely happened. Yeah.
The definitely some ladies
goofed off the poop pile ladder.
It's not as gross or crazy as it
sounds to me. It was normal. I mean,
everybody did it. So it was just
what we did. So I never felt out of,
I never questioned anything.
So, yeah. And how often did you,
what'd you say you participated?
Because sometimes it would happen.
I remember I wasn't there. You
can't force your shit. Right.
So when they call the poop
pile call and they just,
the pill that poupon was stolen or
whatever, you want to take a shit,
you don't go, just stay up
there until you mean you just,
you don't anticipate that time. But there
was so many poo piles. I mean, yeah,
it's like everybody got a turn that was
for sure. Like everybody got a shot. Yeah.
And um hmm.
I'm trying to think.
I mean logistically I was
trying to explain, you know,
the kind of the makeshift ladder in
the tree and you climb out. Yeah.
We had like the, like we had an actual
toilet seat at the end of the tree. Right.
And then it felt totally normal.
I mean,
you sat down and told that you
had the bar to hold on to poop.
I mean it was just, people
don't realize it. Like for the,
for kids it was really a fun,
like come on, do it. I mean,
what kid doesn't love to just drop
a poop, right? Yeah. It's like,
I was like going on a rollercoaster.
You have it to you.
You have an almost two year
old and a three year old.
What happens when you say the word Fart?
Yeah,
they laugh or poop like so they loved
it. They loved it. Kids loved it.
The other neighborhood, like
men definitely loved it and
I almost feel like, yeah,
I think women were intrigued by it.
It was a pretty cool for sure.
Thanks for verifying this stuff.
Poop pile dude. Can you do,
can you remember the call?
Like what does it sound like when we
left the whereby? No, I feel like I,
for some reason I feel like Justin
called out the most like, cause he had,
he would really have a,
he had a good like yelling voice.
He was he a yeller and he would be like,
Oh I probably just screaming
like that. People would dark, dark. It's
like the ice cream truck came through.
Exactly. And they were just were like,
I gotta do this too. Yeah. Very cool.
Not a farm mark.
Yana allow me to present
Casey's testimony,
if I may quote him verbatim.
Now you presented the poop pile,
last week's drawing such that there
were steps nailed on a tree. Yeah.
So as you put it,
a make shift letter.
Now Mr. Casey and his testimony right
now said we had the latter kind of back
where the tree was. Now those are two
separate items. I rest my case. No,
he's saying there's a separate ladder
kind of bad saying there's a separate lab
quote and I quote,
we had the ladder kind of
back where the tree was.
So now in Casey's reminiscences
recollection if you
will about the poop out
there was a ladder kind of backward. The
tree was now in your drawing last week.
Yeah. Nail Lubeck can bring it
up. Yeah. As I'm saying this,
you had individual steps like a
tree house nailed up. Yeah. Now,
which wasn't liar pants. No.
Here's the thing. No, no, no, no.
Those are two separate ways.
No.
Cause you could lay a ladder
against the tree as well. You could,
but you didn't know. I always use the
steps that were nailed to the tree.
But if you wanted to join somebody up
there, maybe somebody who was climbing it,
you put the ladder against the tree.
No two people going up.
He didn't mention that.
Now Casey's testimony did not say that.
Sometimes there was two of us up there.
First of all, there's no mention.
Never have two people pulling.
Oh, sometimes there was half.
Or how is that possible?
Because you would all hang off of that
branch and wait for wanting off of that
rent there.
You said there was only one bar right?
That you could hold onto throwing.
You're telling me that two grown men
are going to share a little bar and hang
their asses off one branch.
No, you're misunderstanding.
Somebody is sitting on
somebody's sitting to shit.
Persons facing him like watching him.
Okay. They switched seats. One one's done.
So one person's holding in their
Shit and coaching the other. This is,
first of all,
this is the first time
you've ever mentioned this
scenario happens all the time.
All the time. Yeah. Uh, I'm
just saying that right now,
Casey's testimony of what
it even physically looked
like doesn't sound or what
you like, what you drew. You mean I'm
going to get video of it at some point.
I'm sure video of what? People
pooping off of it. So you can,
you think of hoophouse still exists.
Shut up. It was legendary. Where is it?
Where, where it's in North Carolina. It's
in North Carolina, was where I lived.
Where, where else would it, do you,
you think that the person who now lives
in this place maintained this ridiculous
thing? I'm sure when they heard stories
about it, they wanted to see what was up.
Yeah.
I like to interview these alleged children
that ran to the scene number pile.
Okay. Why don't they come forward?
I'm sure somebody knows somebody.
The magic of the Internet.
Sure.
You found the bikes kid through
the magic of the Internet. Um,
somebody wanted me to bring up your Moose.
Is this your unbelievable
the lies and this house.
Somebody submits their market. I'm
going to get a metal, a metal detector.
A lie detector. Yeah. We're going
to get to the bottom of this.
I'm over it supposed to be an impression
of the moose soup lady. I remember her.
Okay.
So let's see if this guy
has a good impression.
It's pretty good. Except that the
audio doesn't line up with the video.
I was confused if he was playing the real,
but that was good.
I thought he was playing the real, I know.
That was really, why does it line up?
Because that would indicate
that it's not real.
Hmm.
That's pretty. If it is
him, that was really good.
I know.
Tom, you're there. Yeah, that was great.
Good job, Austin. Before I forget,
I forgot to put it on our
show last week only online.
I posted it and it still blew up
the fucking new try it out. Shirt.
It's right. Yeah. So I didn't even realize
it because the guy was like, he uh,
he messaged me, he was like, oh, people
are 11 to try it out shirt. And I go, oh,
I only posted it online. We
didn't. Uh, there it is. Try it out
your mom's house podcast.
Try it out in the middle.
We also made a women's shirt,
so try it out.
Women's cut, try it out. Shirt is
that, it's kind of trot out inside Joe.
Work friendly. It's kid friendly.
You can wear it anywhere.
Nobody's going to be offended or you
know, creeped out. Just trying to,
it's very life affirming. Very positive.
Yeah. And it's also shows like,
have you not listened to this
podcast chart out the shot? You know,
it's interesting Tom,
is that the try it out.
Guy has made his rounds into our
heart over and over and over again.
And before you left for
this last trip to yeah,
we kind of rediscovered him
as a couple. Yeah, it's true.
It's like some clips that the over time
they kind of unfold and give us more and
more meaning why you're right. And I also
realized that there was parts of, uh,
what he was saying that I was
glancing over, glass it over.
So that's another blast. Like I really
need to pull. Here's the deal, man.
That's so funny.
Says that I never tried to get in
front jail, homeless. Right. With dog,
you want to come move in.
If frankenball did your man free
you Middle Eastern a k fuck me piss.
Somebody beat me on me. Know you see
me my come over today and try it out.
Try it out, man, that
doesn't have here's the deal,
but some of my bills and tried out
and I fuck pissed. Let me try it out.
She has applied only as
fuck, man. I'm looking for
hardcore guys wanting to do it.
I want them to deliver it. I'm a hot
salt, white trash come down for the fuck.
Come dump.
Well, he goes, I'm, I'm a hot white
trash because he's too fired up.
He's really fired up. That's why,
but where's, here's the deal man.
God's love.
The fuck the fuck good.
If you're a hot black guy and you want
to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move
in, you can move in, but you
got to fuck the, I have any,
I need to be fucked a lot.
We got it. We get it for free food,
free rent and everything else, man.
He has a deal,
man.
There it is. Oh Man, I
love, here's the deal man.
Because it's like, it's setting
up what you really need. You know,
here's the deal man.
Well, it's going to be,
and it's like he's really
been ruminating on this. Yeah.
And you know when you're fight,
like you,
you lay in bed at night and you sometimes
think of a confrontation you're going
to have with somebody in the next day.
Yeah.
And you're a kind of lining
up your arguments. Like
that's what he's been doing.
Good. Sitting on this brand on a minute.
I think we should do a quick pause.
Our friend a wheeler Walker Jr is Co.
Okay,
so why don't we take a quick
pause and go see what, try it out.
Try it out with them and we are back.
We uh,
of course you don't know we po.
I like how I act like a little
time has passed to them. Um,
but we are rejoined by,
our friend of the show has been
here before Mr. Wheeler Walker Jr.
Thanks [inaudible] up guys.
Thanks for having me Christina.
So excited to have you back. Jay Dad
mouth. That's correct. I want to champion.
Good to see you. Good. Hey, wait,
what did you just say? Water champion.
He's a water champion. Of course. I
saw on the news you slept on the news.
What News? It's, it's been on the news
before. Have you heard of the poop pile?
You're from the south. The poop pile? No,
I don't know. I mean I know it. Poo is,
I don't want piles are done.
You ever heard of grown men building
like a tree house ladder and then hanging
off of it and pulling in the same pile
together? What do you think of that?
Sounds like a good weekend. We did and
guess where I did it in North Carolina,
which, yeah, I mean, I mean I had never
heard of it, but I'm like, if you,
if you said let's do it now, I'd put
the microphone down, we'd get weed.
I didn't do it. And if I told
you he existed in the Carolinas,
you probably be like, that sounds
believable. If you, if you guessed me,
which state I probably,
what does it do? You Play
Carolina. You must, right?
Yeah, we've done a few times.
I'm going back there, um, uh,
soon. I told you before
we started recording, I'm,
I'm talking with kid rock in the fall and
I think we're doing somewhere in North
Carolina. I forget. They told me the dates
and then that's going to be a fun tour,
man. Yeah, it's crazy. What's,
what's cool about it for me,
which is a new thing for me,
is there, it's country artist,
which is probably different. I don't
know what it's like for, for Comedians,
but it's, we do, it's weekends only.
Yeah. So I'll be in Nashville. Oh wait.
You know, so we get on the bus Thursday
night or Friday, whatever. So yeah,
it's just like a living a normal life
and then you get to go to her on the
weekends. It'll be fun. Yeah. That's going
to be awesome, man. That what you do,
you guys do
pretty much. Pretty much.
Yeah. It's a weekend. Yeah.
Weekend Gig. Yeah. Which, ah,
fuck, that's, that's what makes
it tolerable. Really. Yeah. Well,
years be like week after week after week,
or would it be like,
right. Yeah, I think we're, it's, it'll
be total of three months of three months.
Yeah. Wow. It's a long tour, but it's, uh,
it's going to be fun man. Cause I mean,
that's why I give, I'm giving him some
credit because you know, when I, you know,
I was in, you know, making
the first record, I'm playing,
you know, fuck you bitch,
sit on my face to me these
sound like arena songs.
But then the reality of the world
kind of kicked in. I'm like, Ma, you,
I started playing clubs. Like, you know,
maybe arenas aren't going to happen.
And then when they got the
call like you can't, you know,
you didn't how much they're
going to laugh it off.
And also the coolest thing will be people.
There's going to be people for
sure at the show who were like, oh,
like who's his opening act? Who
is that you got? And then holy,
there's gonna be people
who get there early,
just who want to get, you know,
situated with their fucking hot dog.
And they're absolutely,
they're parents and they're
going to hear me singing like,
what the fuck is going on?
Like when they hear the pussy king,
um, I dunno. I think you're going to,
you're going to win a lot
of new fans on this thing.
Yeah.
And that's a,
that's a good thing about music because
I either win the fans over or I,
when you, if I don't win them over,
I certainly make an impression. Yeah.
They'll know. They'll know your name.
Yeah. Yeah. They'll, they'll, or they'll,
it was like the old hat, you know, I think
it was the Howard stern thing, which is,
you know, the people like you,
you don't tell one person,
people don't like you
tell it like 50 people.
Yeah.
I'd be going nuts if I was at a show and
I didn't know who you were and I heard
these songs, I would be the
guy who was like, I got,
I'd be buying your album in the fucking,
in the audience that right then and there
or do you have any songs about eating
ass?
Can we just,
um, no. Uh, well look, I'm going
to be making my third record soon,
but I've got to get into that,
right?
Yeah.
I mean we were just talking about this
and one of the things we talked about
that we saw a sexpert give advice on,
like bringing it up and
preparing for it and she,
she suggested like a dental dam and I was
like, that kind of is a, I don't know.
I think that's kind of a mood killer.
Yeah.
I mean it seems like you're not
really doing it well. I don't know.
I didn't like her approach to the
ask. It was like, how did it go again?
Do you mind if I make out with your
butt while you masturbate? That was
one of her ways of bringing it up. Yes.
Explain to me what a dental dam is.
Isn't it just a piece of plastic that
you put over a vagine or an a hole and
then you, that's how your tongue, your
tongue, Lex plastic or rubber latex.
I don't know the definition of be nice,
but I can't count.
He must be just crushing box on the road.
You're a musician.
You have all these songs, uh,
that are sexual in nature.
Is it everything you dreamed of?
Well, I got a girlfriend so it's not,
and um,
I'll be honest,
I thought that was kind of a thing in
the industry that you're not supposed to
say here with a woman. Cause well I
think John Lennon wasn't supposed to.
He had a wife, but I ain't
the Beatles. I'm not,
you know how long you been with
this girl? Over a year. I mean it's,
and it's actually real, like I was talking
about, it's nice to, you know, yeah.
To not have to deal with,
he's like fucking road skanks getting
backstage and shit like that. And
then it's just like, you know, so,
so and so wants to go backstage,
told him to fuck off,
you know,
I can't imagine how be
different, I mean, stand up.
It really, you know, there are
Comedians who their, their act
is basically,
it's cording get like they're,
it's an attempt to get laid with
their whole thing is, I mean it's not,
it's not laid out as in I'm
doing this to meet chicks,
but that's what they're doing,
you know, and, and they,
they do their set and it
is an attempt to get laid.
But it's so different
than music where music is,
it cannot be in your idea of your
mindset of this is why I'm doing this.
But I think when people see musicians
perform, you know, men and women,
yeah,
just do it.
It's probably just different
audience people screaming
and drunk and stuff. Sure.
But I'll bet who are the like, you
know, what's the word I'm looking for?
Puente crushers and not, you can't
say their names, but it's probably,
it's probably like the dudes
that you would never imagined.
I heard that a Cosby was well
before he had a trick to that.
Legit like other than those,
those things.
Women, sometimes it's a, it's a
PR. I know a couple, I mean, yeah,
I can't say it on here,
but when we stop I'll tell you,
I'll tell you three verified
absolute just hounds that
that's their whole people said
that to me before, you know,
like man you just did this music
just to get late. And I was like,
in a way I was kind of like,
it kind of annoyed. I was like,
you don't feel the fee.
You know,
you don't feel anything in this music
other than just like a guy and who needs
to get laid, you know? Yeah.
No I think you said that,
but I'm just saying like it,
no,
it annoys me when people say like,
like that's a lot of work to get late
record. Right. They expect that if you're,
if you're a musician that it isn't
worth it mean. Yeah, that's probably,
does she ever get jealous?
Cause you also have a lot of really good
looking women in your videos and you're
singing about like hot
chicks. Like is she like how'd you
meet her? And she ended this stuff.
[inaudible] mutual friend. She, I mean,
she as she loves what I do. We get along.
I mean, we haven't had any problems
with that kind of stuff. Oh, okay.
No jealousy or no, no, no. I mean
I'll bet if you sat her down and said,
would you rather him not call
himself the Pussy King? I'll,
my guess is she probably say, you know,
yes Mr. Walker. Yeah, I prefer that.
Yeah. Or the, you know, the sit at home
watch TV came we'd probably before,
cause I'm, I'm kind of a, you know,
so what I got,
I get rid of me left and right,
but I always there you got to
push it off. Yep. We always
like the women that come up to me w when
the guys ask for Pictures, Oh my God,
when I do stand up,
you know,
I would say 89% maybe more
when my audience is men.
But you also obviously see couples
majority of the time when I meet a couple
after the show, a guy, I'll
be like, hi man, fucking,
it's so great to meet you had a picture
and then I'll be like, sure man.
And then he'll be like bay, but she'll
go, I'm good. I'm all right, fucking here.
And then he'll like, insist, come on, get
back. She's like, no, no, no, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
Well, they're holding up. My thing is, is
there's a lot of couples, they're in law,
you know, it's like,
it's the same thing, but,
and then he gets a picture and
she's like, you know, it's,
this is my birthday gift to him. You
know, I did is I did it as a favor.
I don't need shit.
Yeah. You know, I get, I hear
it a lot. He's been dying
to see you and I go, thanks.
Yeah. And she's like, yeah, yeah, no,
he was really excited tonight
and he really laughed at,
like, she tells me like,
it's a report,
like making sure I know that
question a lot too.
Like,
how do I convince my girlfriend or wife
or whatever it took to get her to go to
a show with me? I'm like, I don't
know if she's not into it, you know,
she doesn't like it. Don't just
go do something else. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a good point. Yeah,
it's, it's, it's very weird.
But this is a tour is going to be,
I think bananas for you.
You're going to pick up so many
new fans. Yeah. Geez. Yeah.
What kind of venues are you doing?
You know,
I think it's, I think it's amphitheaters.
Aha. Yeah, it'll be, it'll be big,
big places. They've got other guy,
Brantley Gilbert who is really big.
He's doing those songs that you,
you have like in those
venues is going to be,
and it's a real cushy gig too
cause you know, we, you know,
we go on so early so I'll be like done.
I'm used to getting done
in fucking midnight.
I'll be done early and it's
the best way to, you know,
get on the bus and walk off and yeah,
cause I'm trying to thank you.
I have your if your latest album,
I have old wheeler on my phone,
man. Finger up my butt. Yeah. I really
love, I'm excited for the, you know,
the kid rock fans who don't know who I am
to hear finger on my button. That kind.
Yeah. I mean, I guess summers
in Kentucky would be what?
Too slow to play on something
like that. Right? To Open. Yeah,
shorter set. So I just try to
just know pounded down it. Yeah,
maybe I'll probably do fuck you. Bitch
is my one valid. That's a great song.
You had to try to play it on here before
I think so your dog.
Yeah,
and I think that'll get some hopefully
get a couple of lighters even though it'd
be probably light a little
lighter outside, but yeah. Yeah.
That's fucking dope man. That's
really, really good news where we've,
we've supported you and we're just so
thrilled that you're doing so well in your
music and you're really talented
songwriter, singer. Great. On the guitar.
Do you ever scan,
do you ever seven debit debit?
How it knows a Scott and I thing a thing.
Oh,
you're not feeling familiar with God.
I know it's getting yes, but it's like,
is it something you guys are into?
We've been getting into it,
trying to figure out whether it requires
skill or if any two year old I was,
I would go for the two year
old angle. But yeah, for me,
I mean the only time I would ever do
that as if I'm working on a song and I
didn't have the lyrics radio I on to
record the melody, I'd do though do it.
Did you know? Yeah, that's
more Babel than a scat. I mean,
what training would you need
for scat? I, it's such a racket.
I don't believe it.
I mean other people who pay way or
there are people who pay you to go see
people's scat. Yeah. Like six
farmers. I think so. Yeah. Uh,
oops. Um, yeah. So anyways, yeah, we,
we mocked somebody that did it on our
show and then most people were into it.
But then we've got a few push
backs about, um, you know,
how talented this person was.
And then we found a woman who won a
grammy for her skin and she was like,
you know, I'm going to have
you won a grammy for. So the
categories, I don't know.
She's like, you know, I don't, I don't
play the Trump, but I am the trumpet.
Yeah. It's like a, what's his name?
The don't worry. Be Happy Guy. Yeah.
Bobby McFerrin. Yeah, I'll
bet he won a grammy for some.
Oh, you're probably right.
Yeah. I mean, here's a little
taste of something else.
Jesus Christ singing is a form of vocal
improvisation using nonsense syllables
imitating musical instruments. You have to
explain it. Sign Jazz. Yeah. And that's,
you don't,
I don't have to go after my,
each side I'll go country music is the
thing where you play your guitar and you
say, you know, it's like,
if you have to explain it to prove that
it's actually music, it's not snowing.
Yeah, man. I just watched, what it
looks like to me is a guy who's like,
I love music, don't want it, don't want
to spend the time and get learning guitar,
Mandolin, piano, whatever, or base.
I'm just going to stand up against the
wall and just start fucking babbling.
I can't remember remembering lyrics is
tough to, yeah, if you just scan it,
just like,
and I noticed his snaps were
kind of off with his scouting.
It wasn't very rhythmic
duet Scott member or,
yeah.
You match
each other's like last note,
take it somewhere else. Yeah.
I mean half their life is probably
proven that there are musicians.
So it just like, it's like I've
never, I don't know anything.
I've never heard of the sketch
show or you know
now how long you're pretty damn good
guitar player. How long it takes you,
you figure it out in like a
day and afternoon. How long
did it take you? I promise
took me, I will say there's a, cause
everyone asks that there's a learning.
It was like a learning curve.
Definitely.
It's like the first week you're just like,
fuck this, I don't want to play. Yeah.
And then there's just a, there's a time
maybe few months and we're just like,
it starts to feel normal and then not,
then you get to a point where
you're just picking, you know? Wow.
But you started very young, yo.
Yeah. It was probably, you know,
11 or 12 or something.
What was the first song you wrote?
Do you remember when you were
11 first song I wrote, um,
I wrote a song with a buddy
of mine back in Kentucky. Um,
my buddy Tyler who,
um,
I won't say his last name because I
think he's got like a normal job now.
We wrote a song called big woman
and it was really bad, but you know,
big woman and we were trying to
do like, um, I think it was quite,
I'm like a big bottoms
like smiled tap guy.
Yeah. Like her, but her butt was
big. I think she was all around big.
She could have been into scad. Definitely.
Well, let's get into it a little more,
Scott.
Lesson.
Things you need to do to scat number
while you need to listen to a lot of jazz
recordings.
Shirley Horn players like the trumpet or
the saxophone because Horn instruments
are very similar to voice. Oh. Since,
because they use a breathing number two,
you need to transcribe.
You don't have to write the notes down.
Just try to sing the solo that you like.
If you can find a track that you like,
you don't have to really
use too much effort.
You will eventually see the Solos.
You understand what he's
advising, right? Yeah.
So mimic the right like
some Sax Solo and then you,
yeah, I can do that.
So he's claiming it's,
I think he's trying to claim it as if
like a cover. What isn't that? Yeah,
it's that kind of plagiarism. I mean
you're not coming up with your own songs.
So is it, what's the talent?
Here's another example.
What do we think?
He basically just singing along
with that, having a little bit, why
should we call it singing along
along with the sound,
because that's a singing along with that,
having to learn the lyrics. Yeah.
He's singing along with like the dark
does just mimic the stuff.
It is crazy that somebody won a grammy.
I want to know this grant. I want to
know that Scott and grammy singer Scat,
grammy, can you think of a worse
thing to have to sit through?
How many they should put it like it
should be the last award of the night and
then our final award, this scat
album, that album on the year. Yeah.
I mean it really is exactly what you
do when you're a little chunks all the
time. A tree, I love my
tree. You've got to create,
is it practice
stage?
And I forgot my lyric
practice, the nonsense syllables.
If you use a best choice
syllables, then it will stutter
your phrase. For instance,
did Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee
or Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, Bubba,
some of them love and they
shut the baffles. Listen,
you can't tell the difference.
Thinking are do up Delia [inaudible]
and my God and number five you get a day
job. Yeah, yeah.
It's a skillset.
Leave it up.
It do.
Maybe that's a sign of something.
You know, something shitty.
Is it for you took like you
took the three best scatters,
I guess maybe do you call them in the
world and then put just two people who
just had learned it two seconds before?
What'd you be able to tell the difference?
It's a great, a great way to, you know,
if you,
if you took,
I think right grace gets put cloud or
next to a guy who just picked up a guitar.
Yup. Yup. That's, that's, see, that's,
that's right. That's the whole thing.
He'd be like, I think that cloud
the guys better than the other guy.
But in scouting you might be
like, I dunno. Yeah. That's
been doing it in a week.
It's pretty fucking good.
I mean, he'd be probably,
I'd probably be more fun to watch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It just, um,
yeah, it seems kind of like
an insane thing to do. Um,
how about there's a whole scene, you know,
like, yeah, like underground, you know,
like, yeah, I think they think it's PR.
I think. I feel like he's got the vibe.
He thinks it's like some new form
of jet, you know, it's like jazz.
It's like the millennial
version of fucking shit.
People have been doing this
horse shit for a long time.
This is all bullshit racket, this
bullshit, man. It's all old stuff. Yeah.
People have been scamming the scat
thing for a minute. Feel like didn't
a song or David Lee Ross like
bat, but dd, but oh yeah,
I ain't got no.
Yeah.
So that would that make him
the world's greatest? That's,
that's gotta be a big scat hit.
Yeah. Cause then there was the,
then he fucked it up by singing, singing
all good and stuff. There was the, um,
the scat man song that was,
was that one, um, the scap man,
you remember that?
But then there's the actual music
around that. That's right. Right,
right. That's breaking the
rules, the free form also,
because there's no structure to it.
The fact that there's no
cost at all structure,
it kind of doesn't make it a song. Right.
I mean, you're a songwriter or wheeler.
It can you just willy nilly,
wow. There's gotta be some
kind of, yeah, that's what I'm,
that's what I keep being confused
about it. Like if you're in the studio,
he goes and the guy goes, let's
try it again. He would be like,
I don't know what it did. What do you
mean try it and try it again? He goes,
the new one will be a new song.
So it's just like whatever.
Like if you had a 10 song
album and just be whatever,
10 pieces of shit you threw out there,
you know,
I kind of think we should try to make
us got album. I think so too. Yeah.
Great idea. Make It, you could do with
these two mikes. Put it out online.
You can make a lot of money. Yeah, we get
a lot of money. Yeah. Scott, the album,
Scott,
maybe we could open for you as your duo.
You too scattered.
You can open every fucking show.
You want them to all sit down with
kid rock and say, I know I go, I know,
I know openers can't have openers,
but I got these two.
Got To get these guys to at
least Scott for a minute for me.
How quickly before we got.
Yeah,
you get hit with for sure.
You know, it would start like
there. People would be like, Huh.
And then once it hit maybe like minute,
although I guess you know, bow with
debar was kind of a scattered a little,
Oh yeah we did bang the bank,
but it probably breaks the rules
by being the same thing every time.
Music. But he always sings, he's
doesn't, he doesn't just go,
sometimes they go Scott,
but did you know Scott
a lap pop his crowd,
we go on him, turn on
him. If he was just sky
the vehicle thing. Because when I
get ready for a tour, like the main,
my main thing, everyone has to get
their voice ready or whatever it is.
My main thing is learning the
fucking lyrics takes me forever.
So scatting would be,
I mean probably probably do scat every
once in while learning your own lyrics.
Learning my own lyrics
is fucking hard because,
because of the way I write is like, you
know, cause people have to, you know, my,
my band has to sing harmony with me
so far. The FIS single wrong line,
they got the wrong way. So it's like
there's some, there's a song called,
can't fuck you off my mind where I
just like while read is blowing me.
I mean it's like I got to
remember who's doing what.
Girls don't want to who to what.
It's like gotta have him all right.
And in order I always, you know, I'm uh,
I have zero musical skill and
when I would do, I can scat.
But when I think that that statement's
doing very basic stuff, you know,
years ago like learn these
four keys, the idea, you know,
I had to put so much
thought into doing it.
One of the things that
seems terrifying is you,
you realize at the time that when
you're doing it and you're like, wow,
I finally got this together,
that to sing while you're doing that,
for some people it would be like, it would
be impossible. I would not be able to.
Yeah. I didn't really sing that
much until I had the guitar to,
I'm pretty good cause I was too shy
about singing and when I first started.
But yeah, I had the guitar
down good enough. So I would,
I actually was when I was a
kid, you know, you could sing.
I knew it but I was too scared to really,
you know,
growing up with a bunch of big family.
I was too,
I was too shy to kind of belt
it out. Um, your siblings? Yeah.
Two brothers do a,
what do they think of your,
I was going to say mixed
things and my mom came,
my mom's from national so she
comes to national lots of sheet.
We had a record release show I think for
the last one and I think that was um,
well the oddest things I've ever done.
She was for the first record,
she came up to the show and I'm
obviously you play no matter what your,
just your eyes. Cause I've always
wear shades on all the time,
but mainly on special on for the lights.
And so I'm playing and I just couldn't,
I had to watch, my mom was thinking,
fuck you bitch. I've never, I've never,
in all my years I've never
seen this look from her,
which was this weird kind
of like proud giant crowd.
You know,
people,
people buying and tee shirts and singing
along and his other like half of our
faces, like, what the fuck did I do
wrong? I was like, mom, this ain't song.
It ain't about you.
You know,
I played the whole song and washed
her face the whole time and I would,
it's not something I would
advise anybody to do.
I don't like having my mom at shows
because you know, I don't sing.
Obviously a bank should come to shown
she's come to shows and usually she'll,
it's some version of
a, that was great. Um,
and then at some point she'll be like,
yeah, why do you the God you say,
I was going to say it's probably exact
same thing, which is I get a lot of,
you know your voices so pretty, you don't
need to say the bad word is, you know,
but that's like, well, all right,
she'll point out another
comic. You're like, you know,
who doesn't even say the F word?
Like, yeah, she's, yeah. She's like,
Garth Brooks doesn't need to say that.
It needs,
it doesn't need to talk about
sitting on people's faces.
I'm why if he did he'd be
even bigger. Yeah, he's sure.
He sure. Here we go. We followed it.
The dream still lives and my dream
is for us to love one another.
All of us.
Oh Gosh, isn't that weird? Oh Oliver,
what dreams still is this was this,
was this the MLK one? Probably,
but also its most generic thing
like you won't even mention MLK.
Just like the dream. Everybody's like
not a lot of emotion and those are
all of us.
And wait,
he leans in and he doesn't really connect
with a while ago cause this dirty.
That sounds like it.
Just for us to love one another.
All of us.
Yeah. Fuck I fucking hate that guy. I
mean it's weird because you say that now.
I mean just because country music
has gotten so shitty, you know,
cause when I was a kid there was all that
good country and Garth came along and
he was the pop sellout.
So I'm still from that era.
But nowadays when there's
such this horrible shit,
people you've probably
never heard of like Florida,
Georgia line and you know all this other
fucking dog shit. It's like pop, pop,
kind of like Florida Georgia line.
We've just got off a tour with
backstreet boys and Nelly have fun.
Have Fun at that one. But I'm saying
like that's the people I hate now,
but at the time it was Garth was
the out. You know, there's a,
there's a famous quote attributed
to Wayland, but we don't,
nobody knows if I'm Waylen said it
or not, but the quote was, you know,
Garth Brooks did to did to country
what panties did to finger fucking,
which I think, I mean, it's definitely
a quote because I said it, but yeah,
definitely a quote, but I don't know
that. And everyone says, it says,
everyone says it's a Waylon. Whoa.
But I don't know if it's a cool quote.
That's a good quote. But it kind
of is, you know, it was like, yeah,
he really just kind of
sanitized it for everything.
It's the most fucking generic.
Oh, that's terrible. Like,
if you didn't wear the cowboy hat would,
you know it was country.
Wow. I, you know what bothers me the most,
cause I don't know much
about country music,
but I just find him to be so insincere
and such a fucking phony baloney.
It's just weird because that's what
country's all about. His sincerity.
What I know is that yeah, you're
supposed to be real and you keep it real,
even if you have a big millions
of dollars. And I just,
I just don't sense that from him. I
just, I don't connect. I don't know.
He seems like he's a sociopath Karma.
It seems fucking crazy because we,
you and I,
you guys and I both watched
those fucking g alerts.
Neither does the g breaks in with the GL
or it couldn't be any less important or
anything. G alert. He's
playing fucking Tulsa.
Yeah.
Glr Taylor let the conversation
creepy. So creepy. And
he's also, he's, he's,
he's just, you remind
me a little bit of, um,
I was just think about
prince today when that,
that other than news kind of came out
about him, uh, whatever they figured out.
What kind of drugs he was on,
but kind of that thing where he
just kind of lost in his own world.
Like he won't, he's not on iTunes. I
don't know if you knew that prince. No.
Garth. Oh, I knew prince. While
you couldn't buy a lot of history,
I didn't know about Garth and Garth will,
first of all his um,
Chris Gaines is wiped from the
Internet. So good. Yeah, but,
but Garth is not on iTunes
or any of the other places.
He's only on Amazon.
Why?
Because he made some fucking giant, well
first before all that shit. He's like,
fuck iTunes man. I'll just make like
Garth's p threes and so on myself.
Yeah, it's on his website. You could
buy like, I really think it was called,
I think it really was called like GP
threes and you get five directly from him.
Like he likes his own initial a lot,
but yeah, exactly. It's like, no dude,
that's not how this shit
works. You know? And it's like,
it's like the idea of
like in the old days,
he would build like a Garth records next
to tower records thinking and people
would just go in there. He's like, I'm
not playing this fucking game. He's like,
I'm only going to make my own versions
of MP three and some on the website.
But people don't go to
people's websites and buy no,
you gotta be where everyone else is
buying albums. But now you finally,
and I'm sure Amazon paid him a shit load
and now here I am endorsing is telling
people to go to Amazon.
But yeah, to own you.
Only way you can listen to in
digitally is Amazon. That's crazy.
What about in the studio? G me Studio
G's. Got It. Let me ask you this about,
I'm still curious cause I know
nothing about it. But you know,
in comedy if a huge comic,
um, once you to open forum,
it's usually a personal connection.
Um,
like you would actually talk to the
person or maybe like their assistant or
something.
But when you book a major music tour,
like this kid rock thing,
is that a purse like d does he call you
or is that just like your agent talked
to his, yeah, my manager talked to
his manager, but I did, I played,
he has a thing called the fish fry.
He's like kid rock fish fry.
It's like a summer festival was in
Nashville and I played that last year.
And uh, we, you know,
talked for a few minutes and he mentioned
maybe torn with him and then he went
on tour and I never heard, like, I was
just like, oh, I guess, yeah, it happened.
Let me call it for this fall
tour. I was just like, obviously,
yeah.
Came around or you know, something opened
up and um, yeah, just got the, you know,
do you want to do it? I'm like, hmm, yeah,
let's play some fucking, you know. Okay.
It's like I was saying before, I can
always picture this music in big places.
To me, they sound like fucking
anthems. So just to even,
even if the crowd isn't true,
my guess is kid rock fans probably get
to the show early and start drinking.
But even it was an empty fucking empathy
or it's still be cool to plug and play
those big fucking
oh yeah, yeah. I bet they get there early
and party. Yeah. Yeah. And by the way,
empty.
There's still thousands.
Exactly. That's the thing too. I got it.
Probably get used to which is
looking out and seeing empty seats,
knowing that still 10 times
the audience I usually play.
It's a pretty crazy, pretty nuts
man. Um, so this is a, I dunno,
this is an anti drinking.
What is this anti drinking
ad from New Zealand.
Okay. I don't know how to, I haven't
seen it yet, but let's see what it is.
Want
it just killed again.
I guess that is a reason not to drink.
It's doesn't seem like
near the top of the list.
No, I mean he was swinging kids
around when they get hammered. I mean,
yeah,
it's not my first,
by the way. I do that sober.
I also wouldn't go crying.
You're crying. Just sit outside. Right?
Sissy. Well, you know,
it'd be interesting is to get a wheeler's
reaction on those videos from last
week. Oh, please. Just which
ones? I know which ones.
Okay. Yeah. I want to see it now
just to tell him I to just watch.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
it actually, that's, he turned out better
than I thought he was going to. I mean,
okay. Face, it's kind of funny, but
that scream, it's a funny screens.
A great screen, but also when
you play it, I was like, fuck,
am I going to watch somebody die?
You and like, that's like, that
guy needs to hit the hit the gym.
That's a good scream.
It's so,
so that's one verified funny. Yeah. Um,
this is a nother one.
This is a guy,
I always hold the cause the last
one then you'd think he's like,
why exactly were they filming that again?
Yeah, I fill him in the car. Come off.
Oh no, he didn't jump that far. I mean,
that's an uncomfortable jump for sure.
But yeah, I mean his, he broke his leg.
That's an off off the top
of a truck thing. You know,
but I'm saying he didn't jump 20 feet,
you know, he probably jumped, what, six,
seven? He played shit. That was probably
like the 12th time he broke his ankle.
So this is a military exercise.
A bunch of guys jump out of a plane
and this guy's parachute is open,
but apparently it's not.
Yeah,
I dunno. Not a hundred percent the way
it's supposed to be. Okay. Okay. So,
so you know,
he's looking at
shit.
How's he in there right now? Yeah.
See they're all, he just knows.
I mean that, that, that's, that
means definitely verify. Funny. Yeah.
That one you don't know sometimes
when you know you're going to get her.
I sometimes scream extra cause it,
I know it all. I kind of, yeah.
I wonder if he's doing that. I don't,
I'm curious what happened to his parents,
but actually supposed to be
called horrible are hilarious.
And you're two for two
that they're hilarious.
Yeah. But also anything with a
parachute if you're okay. I think yeah,
you can use. Okay. Yeah. I don't think
this guy broke anything. Oh, he definitely
leg. Oh, oh,
it was army. Yeah. He knows.
Oh
yeah.
It's not as hilarious. Like I see the
sounds are funny like I get, yeah.
Now by the,
you're laughing at more than that.
Like you like that the guys
are getting hurt. No, I don't.
I think those are a
little bit funny sound.
It's definitely funny if someone is
hurting, it's not you if they live. Yeah,
that's, that's, yeah, no, yeah, yeah,
totally. What I was thinking about that,
I was on a southwest yesterday
and I'm like, I love,
I always get the window seats that people
don't bother me and I'm just sitting
there next to the fucking window,
like looking to my right.
Like does this guy have the
strength to pull me back in?
Like in case it gets sucked down. Yeah.
Cause I actually, I posted on Instagram,
I said, you know, hey southwest, if I get
sucked out this bit before I'm playing,
took off, if I get sucked out this
window, you know, put this window,
make sure this window goes
to the country music hall.
Um, somebody, I dunno who is very, uh,
expressive about pronouncing my name
correctly. I've never had somebody like,
I don't,
hey guys.
So this is a Latin American comedian
that like I am obsessed with,
named Tomas said goodbye and uh,
what's it like?
I always hear people like,
there's a lot of people know him,
but they always the Tom's the girl.
I'm like, yes, I know my security.
I, I feel like, are you lying?
I'm so tired of her running around like
pretending that people's names aren't
pronounced. Like, my name
is Joshua Brown. Okay.
And that's not a hard one to do. Yeah.
So Bert Kreischer no. Yeah, Joshua Brown.
Tomas said
Vladimir Uproot Latin America.
You can start getting it right.
Yeah.
Police.
It's good. It's good point. Joshua,
you got, you got diverse fan. I do.
[inaudible] it's comfortable.
It's nice to see your fans
telling you you're saying
your name. Say My name. Yeah.
Yeah. I would appreciate it if mower
of you said it like Josh did correctly.
Tomas say Google.
Yeah. Yeah. I was actually just thinking
about you the other day because I got it.
I got a new place. I got a new place in
a new place in Nashville and I was the,
the guy runs the building yet
it's like, Oh man, I'm a big,
cause I was kind of hope they don't know
who I am. Yeah, right. I'll fuck is like,
cause they do it.
Got To do background check.
I think it's like they get worried about
maybe not getting excited about the
place, but the dude was cool and
he's like, man, I don't know if you,
you probably get the same thing too.
There's a man I love Tom Segura. Yeah.
I'm just like,
okay,
but you get probably get
about other people. I'm like,
yeah, well I was on his Po,
you know, what are you thinking about me?
Like I mean I get that too. Like shows,
you know, man fucking Rogan,
you know? Yeah. And I'm like,
okay,
I'll see what goes. He go see, I know
I did a show in Atlanta, but I had a,
I had a part in a movie though,
so I've been flying back and forth.
What's the movie? It's
a, a big family comedies.
Instant family doesn't come
out for awhile, but it's a
big movie. Mark Walberg,
Rose Byrne, Octavia Spencer,
like big, big stars in it.
So I'd be friends, man. Thank you.
I'm a flying back and forth and I,
I added a couple of shows to do while
I'm in town because you have days off,
you know, when you're shooting.
And so, uh, for the first one,
a bunch of bunch of crew, you know,
they, they told me they wanted to come,
so I leave tickets for them
and same thing has happened.
I'm going back next week and the next day,
like I didn't see a lot,
most of them after the show,
but I see them the next day on set and a,
a crew people, a woman was like,
I was a lot of fun last night.
We really enjoyed it and I go, thanks.
She goes, do you ever seen John Malaney?
And I go, yeah. She goes,
he's great. And I go, yeah, he
is great. And they're like, yeah, I
love everything he does. And then I go,
he's like, let me think of someone
who does what you do. But who I like.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. And she like, she laid
it out for me and I was like,
no. Like he's very popular.
No, it is funny. Yeah. So
and so it was really funny.
Not You, you just saw me go. Okay.
Yeah. I get that you heard David Allan
Coe. He's fucking awesome. I'm like, yeah,
dig him.
Yeah. Yeah, you should. You should
be like him and you're like, yeah.
Now did the Latins really claim you a
lot? Uh, you, you know what happens?
People claim you,
um,
who enjoy you for whatever they can
claim you for. Sure, sure. Yeah.
I spent time growing up in
Florida. Floridians will be
like, you're a Florida boy.
I was born in Ohio, Ohio. People be
like, you're an Ohioan. Very true.
So if somebody is like,
you know,
I've had people come up to me like
Super Latin people after the show.
You're one of us. Like, they are, you
know, they identify with that part of me.
So they're like,
that's who you are,
right? Yes. What? Everything,
you know, it's like, um, yeah,
I get the Kentucky thing a lot too.
Like there was a map of like, you know,
country stars from Kentucky,
but I'm from central Kentucky
so it was cool cause I was,
they put my face like they show like,
you know,
Stapleton Sturge that everyone's from.
My head's like right in the
fucking middle. Like in there.
Everyone was comments like, you know,
why the fuck is he in the middle?
It's like they're just show him where
he lived, where he lived. Right.
They're all so fucking surrounding.
Yeah.
Well I got it set on Wikipedia. It
says I was born in Toronto, Canada,
which is not true. I'm proud Windsor
native. Right. Windsor, Ontario.
So much better. So much nicer. So much.
What's that last one? I've never been to
Canada. You never been? No, we got it.
I get, well, yeah, we, we
do. The tour is going to hit
there, right? This tour won't,
no. Yeah. No.
I got a tour there sometimes because we
do sell a decent amount of records there.
I got it.
How much of a will the tour hit the
whole nation? What they could arrive one?
Yeah, I mean, I don't
know the exact, I do know,
I know for a fact we're playing California
and I know we're playing New York and
Florida, so those three alone makes me.
Is there an la show? No, there's um,
I don't think or maybe one of the,
you know,
like one of those things that I think
might be kind of considered out lately.
Maybe some kind of, or shoreline
amphitheater. What's that?
The shorelines that San Francisco?
Yeah, it's near there. It's massive.
Like there's something else I've done
the shoreline, it's really crazy.
I do like Riverside or San
Bernardino right outside.
I W I don't remember.
I want to open up for Ted Nugent
way back in the day and he had,
he played like at near Riverside
or something like that.
We open up for Ted Nugent a million years
ago and I was not qualified and I ate
such shit. It was the worst thing
ever. It was like a hard gig.
It's did in the old days. So far, a
lot of comedians open up for rock,
like rock stars. So that
seems, that seems fucking hot.
I would turn it down more than 100%
across the board. I should have.
I just did it knowing it's not
in my audience at all. Dude.
I've almost heard no stories
about,
yeah. One of my first shows, I did
two shows for David Allan Coe and the
cause of the, I didn't get paid shit.
So the first show to, to pay
for a van, the second show,
I just did the first show acoustic by
myself, which is probably close to,
you know, the point being, you
know, you can hear it, you know,
you can hear the fucking crowd talking
to. I just, I just can't stand that.
Yeah, no. [inaudible] has that
great story about opening from a,
for Brendan flowers when the killers,
I don't remember. It's great. It's,
but I mean, I'll let him, I think he's
told it. He may have told it on our show,
but he's definitely told the story yet.
Why Joey Diaz do a bunch of dates
out here with me. How was that?
Was fucking great. That's different
though. It's different. Yeah.
Because he can really get them
psyched. I mean, it was, it was,
it was a perfect match and the shows
are great and people, you know,
he gets heads kind of like a,
there's kind of a, you know,
Rockstar rob where he's like kind of
screening people, you know, and to them.
Plus you go on that podcast
and tell people you're
playing all his guys show up.
So that had to be fine. That
was really fun. Yeah. Um,
was that at the Microsoft something here?
It was something, what was it called?
The Novo and Novo, I think it is. Yeah. I
remember seeing does that big venue. Yeah.
I mean it was big for me.
It was like, um, I dunno.
Theater like 1500 or something. Yeah. But
isn't that, it's a downtown area? Yeah,
I think it, and they have an adjoining
other venue. Bikers. I Dunno.
Here's all, he's the only thing I
know, which I've never made before,
but it's a moms your moms house exclusive.
I hired off Craig's list.
Um, I hired protestors to
hold up, you know, like,
you know, screw wheeler, all this stuff.
And we hired him and fucking
paid to these dudes, whatever,
20 bucks a piece for half
an hour to protest my show
because I was going to film
it and go out there and then I was going
to fight them all. That's hilarious.
And uh, because it's, it's like
that Kinda like downtown area.
It's like there's a bunch of,
it's like across from staples is a bunch
of shit there and they fucking bus,
they,
they wouldn't allow cameras and,
and they made the protesters
leave and I tried to, I was like,
you got to explain it. It's hard to
explain to the cops that it's a fucking,
it's a bit, yeah, I paid
fucking paid them all.
So I had a whole thing ready was
I was going to fucking, you know,
she put him in choke holds and take them
out, you know, and then fucking, you know,
and we, I'd called all the local news
stations to come out too. I'll be dead.
I don't think anyone in my showed up
because there was nothing to show up too.
Yeah, it's too bad. Um, this is a,
if you've ever heard of the pink
preacher. No, this is a guy. I guess he,
I don't know. I'll just, I'll
let you see what he does.
Vino here and I'm joined by the
pink preacher. Awesome man. So, hey,
it's great seeing you here and you look
incredible. I mean, you look awesome.
Thank you man. Yeah, I love
your hair. I mean, thank you.
It's, um, it's also,
that's a such a indicator
when somebody says like,
great to see you or something
and you start laughing. Like,
what are you laughing on man? Why are
you laughing at that? What is your story,
man?
What's your story? A couple,
um, well, basically, um,
three months ago I was in bed
around 11 o'clock at night sleeping.
I'm a great sleeper and God
woke me up and says, uh,
he had me go to my phone and on my phone
was a photo of a billboard that I've
said, read this and it made me
laugh and said, don't go to church.
It's all fake news.
This is, I guess, somewhat reminiscent
of people you see on Hollywood boulevard.
Yeah.
It's exactly to, anytime you hear,
you know, what's your story? This,
this long story. The story begins three
months ago. Yeah, it's not, it's not.
This is not hit his life
calling. Really. Yeah.
What happened is God pushed me in that
night. Now again, it's around 1115 then I,
then I saw that in Oklahoma.
I followed the links in the
article and they said that in, in,
in March or having a atheist
convention. Well, God says,
I want you to go to that convention.
Do you fucking,
I feel like there's people who went to
high school with him who were just like,
oh, Ronny was a piece of shit. Like
they're watching this right now.
That's the look of that guy does not
need to be near the Internet. You know?
It's just like everything. Like God
had me click this link. You God,
God asking me to buy this fucking
plasma screen on Amazon Shit.
You know,
God told me to go order these classes in
that stupid fucking piece of shit goes
to nightclubs and preaches.
The reason I wear the crazy outfit,
I do something called a
nightclub organization outreach.
It's three and a half years ago. I
again, God stopped waking me up at,
I'm not at 11 o'clock three and
a half years ago, I was sleeping.
God woke me up and says,
gold a minister. I said,
where God's seven 11 cause what's open?
He goes,
you're going to go to the nightclubs.
Now Watch,
this guys had been married 10
years. I go in, I said, Hey Ernie,
I'm going to go to the nightclubs because
God wants me to. She says, she says,
okay,
I'll pray for you.
I hate him so much.
He imagined is his probably his wife.
Toni was bringing my weight,
was praying. Do is you want,
you should go out at night to
night clubs and preach. Yeah,
whatever gets you out
of the fucking house.
It gets you away from God's will. Made
it go to strip clubs. Dance isn't Duke.
Okay.
So do you remember the guy that made
obviously the prank call your voice?
So we had a listener make a call
using Christina's voice,
her actual voice recordings
of her call a sex line,
and talked to the sec operator
that she was into scat play.
Like I'm not singing, but
it was from fans. And uh,
even when they had Christina go too far,
uh,
like said something about Hitler
and the sex operator was like,
that's a little too much for me. I'm
like, it was really, really well done.
Now they are having,
uh,
I guess this is a call that they used me,
my voice,
I think Ari Jo and maybe Burt,
I haven't heard it.
I just know that
this is, is it the same dude? I think
that the same guy made it. Yeah,
same guy made it.
Yeah.
Hey. Hey. How's it going? Good.
How are you even joined the day?
Uh, to tell you the truth, where
I live, it's 80 degrees today. Uh,
we begin hit with a lot of snow and stuff.
So it's been beautiful.
I've been hanging out on the back porch,
drinking gin and tonics
to tell you the truth.
Fantastic.
That sounds great.
Me and the birds and the birds.
Well,
you're sitting on the back porch listening
to the birds and I'm sitting here
playing with this big
pecker and watching porn.
Right? Yeah. When I sit outside,
I normally am my hand and I'm like
pants mine with pine nuts anyway, but,
oh wow. Listening to
the birds. Yeah. Yeah.
And how big your packer or by the
way? It's all right. Six and a half.
But I got girth fixing.
It happened at night.
I invited some friends over
cause we really want you to,
uh, to listen to us. Fuck
all the guys at that point, they're
like, man, you have a hot car.
Oh Man, I bet your cock is beautiful. Oh,
I think that's somebody coming
that company.
Hey, how's it going man? Oh, hey Tom,
my friend Tom just got here eight times.
He looked great.
Tom showered today. He's smart.
Really good. What do you want to do,
Tom? Let's Jack off and do you
want to see Tom and I jack off?
Uh, I'd love to see not, are you kidding?
This is really just one sec.
I'm going to go get your favorite
big mushy purple Dildo. Hold on.
No Way. Come on. Touch it. Put your
hand on it. All right. You're ready Tom?
Yeah, I'm trying to nut. All right.
I'm about to hook up with a guy right now.
There's a lot more. Yeah, I love it. I'm
really impressed with his, he's like a,
it's a lot of word. It's a
lot more professional. Yeah.
Oh Wow. What do you want to do now,
Tom? Just pick up the pace a little bit.
Do you like, uh, circumcise Cox? Yeah,
actually I'll says he's got a
beautiful circumcise cock. I do.
How do you want it, Tom? I wanted
hardcore. Want to see it going in and out?
Fuck Tom. Get ready. You know
what we're here to do. Oh,
okay.
Somebody else's.
Oh, it's uncle Joey under
the stick it in your ass.
Why don't we just hang out and come on
each other? Yeah, just put it in my ass.
And you have to be gentlemen.
Oh really?
Crazy.
Because the real thing is
jerky
really big Dick Machine on your ass.
Oh, Joe Rogan Shit. Holy
Shit. What is this? Whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
You to go fuck t bonds in as pooper.
Okay.
In the same hall.
At some point you don't need the
gun in the other end. I know, right?
Great. Now it's a bird. Oh, I'm back baby.
I love them guys.
It's making my stomach. It's a lot
of noise, but it's really well done.
She knew this guy is a math. I love
these people. Now people don't have,
not that many people have
jobs, you know, they got shit.
They just got so much time. Do you know
they learned, think about all that.
They learn to be an engineer.
So they learned how to like grab
clips from the fucking, you know,
iTunes or the internet or whatever. All
that shit. Take hours and hours. Tom.
Most of these clubs I remember from our
show. From your pumps. Yeah, I know.
This is all on our show.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Was that,
I'm curious what joy was talking about.
[inaudible]
sorry.
Oh my God, it hurts.
Fuck, I got hurt so bad. This
card, what's the big deal?
Jesus
is real degenerates
there.
Just like a constant like
guys in the background,
guys just doing this guy's fucking
in the background. Really intense.
There's one last clip I have to,
we owe them the respect to play the last,
how does it end?
Yes.
[inaudible]
your time is up for this
call. Goodbye. That's it.
You don't get,
you don't really tie up the story.
A lot of guys,
I don't even know that.
It doesn't even say the name here, but
you really are a master of these. Jesus.
Really, really impressed.
Thank you for doing that.
They prayed to pay a ton for that
call too. Yeah, that's true. You know,
my friends,
we'd get those like $100.
Their parents will get those
hundred dollar bill, you know,
you'd call sex operators.
We prank him. You know,
cause I think it was kind
of like we wanted to,
we were horny that we
actually wanted to call them,
but we didn't pretend it was a prank, you
know? Right, right. You know, like tell,
you know, talk about your boobs. You know,
you get real sexual and we'd just be
fucking giggling and shit and then
they call my parents and like, I wasn't
like 100 bucks a hundred bucks for that.
It was always you. They're like wheeler
came over. Yeah. I mean it was, it was,
it was fucking, I mean, well you're from
kind of a smaller place to was just,
there's just nothing. The fucking dude.
Yeah. I never did it. I never called.
I think it was probably more terrified
of, of uh, getting in trouble. Yeah. Yeah.
You do much print and print calling
though. We did some prank calling.
I remember one time in the, in
the sort of the same way, uh,
would prank call cute girl.
Like girls we liked from school
call and hang up or like, you know,
do voices. Yeah. It was fun
before caller ID and shit.
I remember before Koller idea girl
knew that was so terrible. We used to,
we had one buddy who had,
um,
who was the first guy we ever
knew who his parents are.
I think his dad was in some kind of
business. They had two phone lines.
So we would do the,
we would call two people at the same time
and if they picked up at the same time,
they'd be talking to each other. So we
would call like a girl in high school,
like a guy who had a crush on a girl in
high school and you just hook them up
together.
So he thought she called and she thought
he caught and they're just like that,
you know,
who is this?
You know, that's really
easy. Oh it's Brad, you know?
Oh thanks for calling.
I didn't call you anything.
We just listened to them basically
because we were basically gels, you know?
Of course, you know when this girl
told me, this is like fifth grade man,
she was like, I know that you
called me. And I was like,
I didn't call because we'd called
obviously and I don't know how they,
I back then it was like you
have to ask the operator. We, I,
we had busted a couple of times
people would, uh, call. Yeah.
I don't know if it was the
cops or somebody within you
that I just got a threat
on the phone. Can you yeah.
And you have to get like a,
I remember you get like a, um,
like a reverse phone phone book.
It tells you what the numbers are.
Yeah. Um, yeah, I dunno. It definitely
the game changed for sure when,
uh,
when it became everybody has caller Id
d oh yeah. Cause I, you know,
I'm doing the wheeler podcast where
people calling on my voicemail and leave
messages. So I did it, you know,
obviously I want it to be real,
having a real phone and now it is
a real song, but got a new phone.
So we're doing it when
people have cut podcasts,
people calling all answer the questions.
What line do they call it? You, you,
you get a second line. Yeah,
I got a second line for me,
but it's still my real name. This one's
don't want real number. Oh, it is?
It's on my,
it's on my Twitter and my Instagram.
You can call in and leave messages.
The messages wheeler,
the Wheeler Walker Jr podcast. It's
just a season two coming up. Um,
the same people, the ATC though seem
dude's you're working with? Um, oh yeah,
they're great. They're
awesome. Yeah. Yeah.
Helped me out a ton on it because I
can't do all that fucking shit. I can't,
I'm not, this guy can't
edit and shit, you know?
Yeah. Um, you don't have a,
I've had a bunch of bets challenges
with Bert Kreischer and uh,
and you fucking killed him on the
weigh loss. Oh yeah. Yeah. Let's look.
You're still keeping it off
to yeah. Try and men, um,
my workout four or five days a week.
Try not to eat dog shit all the time,
but this is a dog shit eating
challenge. So you know,
doughnut holes. Oh fuck. Yeah.
We're going to see who can eat more
than 12 minutes. Who's, who's wheat?
Burt and I. Oh, it's a contest.
It's kind of the anti contents that you
had before. It is the anti contest. I'm,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna. I'm gonna, I
dunno. I think I feel like births,
the Kinda guy who could really wove some
food down and he feels like he's like
been at a million parties where
people have lost money betting against
him on and know somebody you prior to
sing at all.
Now this, this somebody said
here, this is a no suggestion.
Famous drinking game of participating.
Call it power hour.
It's the rules are simple.
Drink one shot of beer every minute
for an hour straight. No more or less.
I feel like this would be a great
dynamic for the donut challenge.
Simply set an alarm to go off.
Eat one or two doughnut holes every
minute until one of you taps out. No,
because that would take too long. I
don't want to fucking ass. No Fun.
That was a horrible so you got to do one.
Yeah, you can do it on a podcast or sad.
That's why we set a time limit. It's about
how many can you eat in a time limit.
Do you think? Part of his thing
we'll be doing or either one.
Are you going to do more than like
show a bunch in at once? Well,
I saw him yesterday,
I'm on Instagram on his stories.
He was at the airport and he stopped by
a Krispy Kreme and he kept posting him
self eating different donuts. Like yeah,
it's, it's a, it's a good question.
Which is theory would work
the best because it's like
one a time you can go fast,
but like five at a time, it takes
longer to chew. Figuring out the donut
challenge, you know. And what are we
talking about now? Which part of the same?
Like would you do multiple ones at once?
Like in other words it was called,
you could do like grandma, man.
Well it's time. The essence. Yeah.
You're up against the clock. How
much? 12 minute time limit. Ooh. Yeah.
And I think that's the advantage of
doing the doughnut holes is that you can
train two at a time. You're
right, you can go one.
I was gonna say maybe squash them
together and then that's a good idea.
But that might be an unfair thing.
What if it crumbs leave and then now that
that contributes to it being a lesser
donuts and interest, that's
volume. Yeah, we got it. We got,
who's the judge for this? I am.
She's going to be the judge.
I'll have to think this
through. I got it. Yeah.
Say the more I taught,
I've talked to people about it.
The more I realize how formidable
and opponent for eating Burdis no.
Everyone has been saying and they're like,
I bet that Duke can crush them. Donuts.
No,
wait,
now have you two decided on the type?
Is that an old fashioned doughnut hole?
Chocolate. I'll call him after this.
I think we should decide and you guys
should have to do the same type of donut.
It only seems fair.
Yeah. I'll let him pick. I
let him pick. Okay. You're,
it feels like glazed would be the
one that's the old, the classic.
I think that's going to be
less dense than the chocolate,
but for some reason the chocolate
donut holes, chocolates.
I think the other thing you're going to
think about is I think as I'm thinking
about, I think you're going to
realize how long 12 minutes is.
Ooh, it's like a point you're
going to be shoving him in your,
I'm thinking like how much longer are
you just going to let you remember?
11 minutes.
30 so it's a good point.
Cause how long is Nathan's
hot dog eating contest?
It's like that's nothing for a couple of
minutes. Yeah. Yeah. Those guys. Yeah,
you're allowed to do that because that's
their big thing is water, right? Yeah.
Yeah. You can, that you can do
water, get them wet and shoved them.
Now do we want to allow,
that's a good point. Wheeler,
do we want to allow water dunking
and milk or what do you want to,
can you add hot to hot dog buns?
I'm just thinking about
how long 12 minutes is.
So you can do a lot in 12 minutes.
I mean, what's, uh, what's,
I mean like the coffee, how long
was the Cosby show? I was like,
it's like half the colony to ice.
Does watching the Cosby show.
I didn't do,
I didn't eat them nonstop.
I have to show the last time
I feel pretty full. And then you're
like, you got seven minutes left, so,
so then maybe take a little break.
Maybe the challenge here is not
so much cramming two at a time,
but pacing yourself.
Finding what that pace.
Yeah, I'll bet the winners. If you
just one one one is the way to do it,
then you just,
if you eat a boy that's just not
going to make yourself sick and you just
do it, you know, tortoise and the hare.
But see that's the thing is I
don't think he'll go slow. No,
I think he'll do three at a time
nonstop for 12 minutes. Yeah.
I think the final score is going to be
some funny like 82 to six or something.
I think you're right.
I think that Burke tends to go in excess.
He's good to do the Mickey Mantle
Jean thing and like really cramps.
You know, people have told
me, you friends, men, uh,
you eat fast.
And then I've only been in awe of him.
I've never even come close to his.
Yeah. Here's my, here's my advice and
I don't like giving people advice,
but you got to stop challenging
a guy whose name is the
machine. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
You know, he emceed and get them. It's not
some nickname that just popped up. Yeah.
And he's a machine at every,
I mean he probably got them name
machine probably started somewhere with
doughnut holes.
Yeah. Well I'm a, I am
worried about you. I mean you,
I think it's a certainty that you're gonna
get sick. Yeah. I'm going to get sick.
I'm going to get sick.
Yeah.
I think that's true.
I think that should be a rule that if,
I mean diarrhea didn't yell, but
if you throw up, but you can count.
I think that's how it is.
A Nathan's hot dog eating contest.
There's a certain time you have to fold
it. The hot dog for a moment. Yeah. Yeah.
So maybe we could do that. We have to
hold it in for a certain amount of time.
I'm definitely gonna have
diarrhea 100% you think diary. Oh,
you know, while I'm on the road, I
would say nothing gives me worse.
You talking about what?
Why ladies don't show up my shows
because I had to want to talk about,
but the worst, nothing gives me
the shit worse than glazed donuts.
I don't know why. I don't know what
it is. All that sugar. It's just so,
it's just like, it's just not,
we have not good for your,
it doesn't affect me that way. It makes
my stomach hurt, but I don't shit, dude,
can we get a phone before we wrap up?
Yeah. I'll say, how have I seen
my new single? Oh Wow. Okay. Yeah.
I don't really have
single ladies make videos.
Don't wanna tell you about the
video. So I was at it. There's this,
there was this guy,
um,
his name is Reginald big
black guy with a cowboy hat.
He calls himself wheeler
with a tan and he, he, um,
lip syncs to my videos all the time and
I'm putting on Instagram and then he
can't, he can't come do a show in
Dallas. And I just see it. I was like,
it was like seeing my soup, my
hero come life. He's like, man,
I want to do a video video for
you. I was like, fuck. Yeah.
Like I was number and is, this is a song
on my album called if my dick is up,
why am I down? Yeah. I remember that
song and then he made it. I was like,
if you could shoot this
video from a couple angles,
we'll edit it together into a video.
MMM.
And he did it. It was pretty fucking cool.
That's awesome. Well, thanks Reginald.
You want me grab my guitar?
Okay, great. Yeah, this is great.
Okay.
How many of you think you could
eat in 12 minutes? I don't know.
It's picking the number. Seems
really scary. How about one minute?
I think about 60 seconds.
That's, what do you think?
And then,
I don't know,
five in a minute.
Oh No.
25 25 yeah. 25 minutes. No.
Yeah, I think you might get a
little sick one every 20 seconds.
Maybe it's realistic. I, Tom,
I think the key is to be realistic
here because then you're going to pace
yourself. We've got to train
it, train on the pacing. Well,
there's a difference between going for,
there's a difference between going for
one minute and go on for [inaudible]. Uh,
you can add to this point.
Just do whatever you need to do.
Hmm.
It's a little early for me,
so I'm not sure about my voice.
Should I do my alarm ups?
I went to a guy once for
the vocal training, not,
it didn't seem to need to train my
wanting to learn how to like warm up every
night and yeah, taught me my good. He
goes, you just go Google, Google, Google.
And so I do like goose. Oh you do?
Yeah. I'll give him a little more Mike.
We pull the mic a little closer.
You can pull it. You can move it.
Yeah.
Girls,
I use
Jack off to ask him to class
for a bag.
Ladies get Rawlins town.
So if
Monday
women, none. Never man tits up.
So why Track Brown?
My Dick is up.
Tell me why I'm Ma
wait,
a girl show and her and
before we shake hands,
she started
swelling.
Matt Brown soap Monday
may suck in mail route.
So
one girl is believing
there's to walk through.
Now I've learned a pussy
while I'm wearing frown self.
My big
[inaudible]
son
ladies.
I'm never Sam saying they won't
sit down while named
Marine Shannon around.
So my neck,
my neck is up. Me. Why?
Wow.
Real man. Really good. That's really
great. Thanks. Really Nice. Beautiful.
Well that be, you think that'll be a live
one to play the amphitheater tour now
I want it worries a little bit on the
slower side. Right? Which one are you?
Queer is going to suck. My Dick is nice
rock. I think that's good one for the kid.
Rock fans. They'll kind of the
rockers. He posey kicking ass.
I'll probably do more up
tempo stuff. Would you? Oh,
you got to open with a bag too, I
assume, right? Yeah, I think, uh,
well I don't want to give too much away.
I don't know.
I don't know how much the kid rock podcast
audience Crocker's crosses with your
mom, your mom's house. But probably
open with sit on my face, you know,
just to get the,
let the crowd know what's though.
Let him know what's up. That's
awesome man. I'm really happy for you.
Congrats on that. Thanks man. Thanks for
having me back. I love you guys. Yeah,
it's great. Always great to Wheeler Walker
Jr if you don't have a old wheeler, uh,
the latest album, it's
fantastic. Or you can catch him
on tour, um, later this year.
Opening for credit rock on
a major amphitheater tour.
And you have the wheeler podcast.
Yeah, well the wheel Walker Jr
podcasts probably be season two.
I call them seasons because I
take months off between, yeah. Um,
probably be up in the next couple of
weeks. I don't know when this airs,
but it'll probably be up
close to one this year.
All right. Um, thanks for
coming. Uh, your mom's house,
podcast.com. And don't forget,
you can get tickets to see us live.
Christina p online.com [inaudible] dot
com and a follow a wheeler Walker Jr.
All right.
Thanks brother.
And this is a right now by Dj right now.
Thanks for listening.
Bye guys.
Right now,
right now.
Right now. Right now. Right now.
Right now with me on a name right now.
I know right now, right now. Right now.
Right now.
Make a cruise that you'll
remember for a lifetime.
Anything else right now? Right now?
Right now?
Right now.
All right now,
right now,
right.
Oh,
right now. Right now.
Right now. Right now.